two roads a few houses this is
Sutherland in the karoo a semi-desert a
five hour drive from Cape Town guest
houses here are named after planets or
galaxies and mock up telescopes signal
to any visitor that this is the place to
be in South Africa for stargazers up on
the hill is the most important
astronomical observatory on the African
continent the telescope facility of the
country's National Research Foundation
here nature and high-tech live in
peaceful coexistence the Springboks are
mainly drawn to the compound by the
grass that grows all around it
astronomers come for the hardware to be
specific for the South African large
telescope or salt it's the largest
single telescope in the southern
hemisphere
financed by several different countries
including Germany this eye on the sky
was completed in 2005 made up of 91
hexagonal segments its enormous mirror
is 11 metres wide and 10 long the
segment's have to be aligned correctly
to 1 millionth of a millimetre to bring
images clearly into focus two things you
can do with a really large telescope is
you can look at very faint things or you
can look at brighter things put on very
short time scales and so it's
interesting to study things that vary on
time scales of of minutes and seconds
and we can actually do that with all of
our instruments have that capability to
do high-speed work researchers here can
observe how compact star remnants absorb
gasps from companion stars for instance
until they have so much mass that they
explode as supernovas or watch as black
holes suck in endless amounts of stellar
dust the astronomers want to investigate
the universe more thoroughly this
Spectre graph from the United States
will soon get an armed with new
measuring devices they will allow it to
collect data about thermal radiation
from space and can observe regions
hidden behind dust clouds the
instruments have to be mounted on this
black beam it's a complex device that
follows the movements of the sky
the new instruments will allow the
astronomers to look deeper into the
universe and even more detail and
they'll be able to see the tiny
movements of stars that's the first step
towards detecting small rocky planets
that orbit far away suns and there a
particular interest because they could
be home to alien life David Gill banks
team of researchers use salt to
investigate how galaxies develop that's
a central question in modern astronomy
they're observing what are known as
mergers galaxies that look as if they're
fusing together the spectrographs break
up the light of these celestial objects
into the colors that make up its
spectrum what we do with the spectra is
we measure how fast their movement which
tells us what distance they're moving at
and then that tells us if the relative
velocity between them if there's a small
difference in speed between them that
means that they're likely to merge
together and if there's a large distance
between they're not going to merge
together so we know that they're not
true mergers and spectroscopy is the
only way to tell us the images recorded
by salt and other big telescopes both on
the ground and in space are being
compiled into the astronomical virtual
Observatory it's a huge library that
researchers all over the world can use
gleaning new knowledge from the trove of
data to uncover the mysteries of the
universe
you